[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et merci de nous
rejoindre pour ce nouveau numéro de 7,8
débat le porte parole du gouvernement
christophe castaner l'a confirmé une
hausse de 10% des taxes sur le diesel
une augmentation prévue dans le projet
de loi des finances 2010 huit objectifs
aligner la fiscalité du diesel sur celle
de l'essence fini le gazole moins cher
fin du différentiel et sans diesel
nouveau départ pour la fiscalité
écologique limitation des émissions de
polluants le carburant le plus vendu en
france est dans le collimateur du
gouvernement
mais augmenter les taxes sur les diesels
est ce la solution
en plateau avec nous ce soir pour en
débattre if kara porte-parole
d'automobiles clubs associations et
ghislaine séné conseillère régionale
maire écologie les verts développement
bonsoir à tous les deux et bienvenue sur
ce plateau il carats je me tourne vers
vous pour commencer ce débat taxe et le
diesel c'est une proposition honnête
pour équilibrer les prix du carburant
alors pu équilibrer les prix du
carburant à la hausse
pour nous c'est pas la bonne solution
enfin pour nous je dirais pour les
français c'est pas la bonne solution
il ya surtout une chose que je trouve
que je trouve anormal
on fait confiance par exemple aux
entrepreneurs en leur disant on vous
baisse les charges on vous demande rien
en échange
mais on vous fait confiance votre
intérêt pour votre entreprise c'est
d'embaucher ces terres de la recherche
et développement cessé de faire tourner
votre entreprise d'investir donc on fait
confiance alors aux français dolby liste
on est quasiment tous tous
automobilistes donc aux français on leur
fait pas confiance on leur dit pas où
est ce qu'on va faire on va baisser le
diesel au prix de l'essence et ont fait
confiance puisque un diesel c'est plus
cher à l'achat plus cher à l'entretien
et que effectivement les polluants sont
plus agressifs pour notre santé donc
votre sens civique farc d'aller acheter
de l'essence ça marche pas dans ce sens
donc on prend on tord le bras des
français en leur disant on va vous
obliger à acheter de l'essence parce
qu'on va augmenter le prix du diesel
donc nous dire c'est pour votre bien on
augmente le diesel je trouve que c'est
énorme d'autant plus que dans le même
temps le gouvernement augmente les sens
3 9 centimes donc on va augmenter le
diesel augmenté l'essence augmenté de 2
on va jusqu'où comme ça le matraquage
fiscal de l'automobiliste est énorme
à sept jours d'une vache à lait on le
sait mais là quand même nous dire on
augmente le diesel pour votre bien c'est
quand même le grand quoi c'est à dire au
delà de matraquage fiscal ce qu'il faut
surtout prendre en compte c'est
effectivement finalement une volonté une
démarche qui est certes hypocrite et je
pense rejoindre là dessus c'est essayer
d'aligner les deux les deux carburants
disant 'vous voyez finalement le choix
au fur et à mesure veut que il va
falloir que vous lâchiez sur sur le
diesel mais aujourd'hui on a une vraie
urgence et les pouvoirs publics doivent
absolument faire en sorte que le diesel
qui est aujourd'hui la motorisation la
plus controversée la plus polluante et
qui est la plus utilisée ici en france
doit une bonne fois pour toutes
cc et s'arrêter donc il faudrait au lieu
que la communauté européenne
lâche et diminue finalement les normes
sur sur l'épaulement on devrait une
bonne fois pour toute et sans hypocrisie
dire le diesel c'est terminé et puis
comment on accompagne maintenant les
français pour effectivement un pouvoir
changer de véhicule pardon mais depuis
2012 le diesel déjà la part du diesel en
france diminue puisqu'on est passé de
plus de 70 % à 50 % donc le nombre de
voitures diesel spontanément un diminue
la grille depuis les affaires les ouïes
la connaissance en plus de 10 en 2015
mais ça l'est déjà commencé à me dire
avant puisque ça va commencer en 2012
déjà
ce qu'effectivement il faut savoir quand
même une chose c'est vrai que c'est une
aberration
d'abord fiscal qu'on a eu en france donc
on va pas revenir dessus on va pas
refaire l'histoire du pays mais il faut
savoir que pour acheter un diesel faut
que l'on ait une utilisation vraiment
particulière d'un diesel d'abord pour
dépolluer un diesel sur les petites
voitures ça coûte cher c'est pas très
efficace vaut mieux une grosse cylindrée
ce pour ça que les allemands ont des
grosses cylindrées c'est plus efficace
ça coûte cher à peu près 1000 euros par
voiture dépolluer nouvelles tumeurs un
diesel que le diesel à froid en ville ça
consomme énormément ça pollue parce
qu'un moteur froid diesel ça peut lui
beaucoup donc si vous achetez un diesel
c'est de préférence une grosse cylindrée
de préférence sur des très longs trajets
sur autoroute ou sur sur nationale n'est
pas en ville et et puis surtout il faut
faire au moins de trente ou quarante
mille kilomètres par an voilà dans ces
conditions là je ne conseille pas
d'acheter un diesel mais le diesel peut
être efficace moi j'ai une voiture
diesel
c'est une voiture de société de ma
compagne on fait de moins de 5 litres
sur autoroute à 130 kilomètres heure
c'est très très peu willow rosé quel est
le rôle des constructeurs automobiles
justement dans cette prise de décision
là on est en train de parler d'aidé des
voitures est extrêmement important enfin
on voit bien d'ailleurs que les lobbys
au des comptes twitter dont il a fait a
réussi à alors que ça fait puis
effectivement vous l'avez rappelé depuis
2012 sur lequel on a aujourd'hui de
réelles accusations sur sur notamment la
qualifia la qualité de l'air et
notamment l'île de france mais je pense
aussi à la vallée de l'arve enfin tous
les sujets qu'on a pu avoir aujourd'hui
il y a réellement une volonté de pouvoir
continuer parce que le diesel était le
fleuron de l'industrie automobile du
carburant acheté en france de deux
heures aujourd'hui j'aurais oui tout à
fait agréable à skier c'est la france
est encore une exception les
particuliers professionnels et et ça a
été porté par les différents
gouvernements qui ont vraiment financés
par ce que parce que moi c'était mais
c'est comme d'habitude je ferai
évidemment parallèle c'est qu'à un
moment donné on a une technologie et qui
aujourd'hui effectivement n'est pas
encore remplaçable notamment sur les
gros tracteurs faire les gros véhicules
et là on
effectivement un vrai gap technologique
a passé mais mais moi ce que je déplore
réellement c'est que déjà on est
toujours dans un hôtel tout routier sur
dans les modèles de développement et de
croissance que l'on peut porter
aujourd'hui ici en france et puis
surtout c'est que on a eu réellement une
une politique très
[Musique]
très hypocrite j'aurais emploie le mot
mais qui était de dire on va
effectivement là aujourd'hui on a des
personnes qu'on a poussé à acheter du
diesel
mais bon on va petit à petit les
accompagner alors que fin ça fait déjà
quatre ans cinq ans sur lequel si on
avait pris des décisions
ces pouvoirs publics avaient pris des
décisions fermes et bien on ferait déjà
dans une transition est une mutation au
niveau des constructeurs automobiles
j'oublie ged et du gouvernement en la
recevant structures automobiles
ils ont des centaines de milliers
d'employés ils ont des chèques à faire à
la fin du mois de salaire et on peut pas
dire à quelqu'un qu'on a formé en
diéséliste en 2007 par exemple pour le
dernier beaugrenelle pour dernier
grenelle de l'environnement dieuze et 10
c'est un métier d'avenir dix ans après
il faut leur forme est il ce qui peut le
faire enfin c'est compliqué eux ils ont
des vraies responsabilités mais ce que
je dois rappeler aussi dans tout ce qui
est généré comme pollution par l'être
humain sur cette planète
on est d'accord le but ultime dans cette
humanité s'est abîmé le moins possible
la planète que ce soit pollution des
sols des nappes phréatiques de l'air
pollution de notre alimentation d'ascain
de ce qu'on a dans l'assiette
moi j'aimerais qu'on ait autant
d'attentes et d'exigence vis-à-vis de
toutes les sociétés qui vendent des
polluants à nos agriculteurs qui
polluent les sols les eaux et tout le
reste et qui arrivent dans nos assiettes
j'aimerais qu'on ait autant de 2,2
demande un peu irrationnel et et
voudrait dans toute la pollution qui est
fait notamment ville je rappelle elle a
sa part nous sommes d'accord mais la
voiture c'est moins de 30 % de la
pollution et même à grenoble qui est une
ville très pollué l'hiver écoutez bien
c'est pas moi qui le dis à vous trouver
l'hiver à grenoble une vitre à polluer
qui prend des mesures
les particules fines sont responsables
70 % des particules fines en hiver c'est
le chauffage au bois que 30% pour la
voiture donc faux pas de tomber que sur
la voiture rien qu un côté un peu
irrationnel mais plus cher c'est un
tiercé qu'on peut on peut pas ferran
chauffage au bois alterné alors
forcément son fameux critères vous savez
moi j'ai eu l'expérience de pouvoir être
président de la commission de la sortie
du diesel des bus et autocars
au stif au mandat précédent le chantage
à l'emploi
immédiatement c'est ce qui nous a été
mis en avant c'est à dire vous vous
rendez compte les chaînes de montage on
va pouvoir leur site venait de sortir
évidemment il y avait eu des
investissements qui avait été fait et
ouhlala vous vous rendez pas compte à
quel point ça va être compliqué de faire
évoluer l'outil industriel
or le thé industriels il s'adapte au
marché et lorsque et on le voit bien aux
etats unis aujourd'hui un aujourd'hui
sur la voiture particulière c'est plus
du tout par le diesel n'a jamais été
dangereux car aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
le tout électrique i qui a pris qui a
pris le pas on a aujourd'hui
toujours eu cette tendance et ses freins
ici en france a essayé de tenter de
rentabiliser ou voilà de faire perdurer
en tout cas les gains sur sur des
technologies dans lesquels on avait pu
investir et je pense qu'il ya quand même
eu une volonté manifeste de la part des
constructeurs de rester sur leurs acquis
et pas forcément de relever on voit
l'expérience alors je parle d'un
équipementier mais valéo qui était
réellement 2008 en début de la crise
dans une très grosse difficulté qu'a
fait un vrai choix de stratégie de dire
bon ben ok on arrête sur les moteurs
thermiques qui ont uni sur le tout
électrique et aujourd'hui il a fait un
vrai choix stratégiques jo défend le web
non mais alors il faut faire attention
il ya d un timing politique qui ne
correspond pas au timing industriels et
quand on met des quand on prend des
décisions
je trouve qu'il faudrait plutôt discuter
avec les industriels dire bon ok on va
dans une autre direction comment on fait
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour pâques
et de casse sociale ou autre c'est
important quand même de penser à ça et
ce timing l'a souvent les politiques ne
le prennent pas en compte deux ils vont
peut-être trop vite pour les industriels
et en ce qui concerne le tout électrique
si on prend l'exemple de la chine qui
part donc tout électrique c'est pas des
voitures électriques qu'ils ont c'est
une voiture à charbon alors parce qu'il
faut le produire l'électricité mais oui
et oui c'est une réalité c'est le
excusez moi oui c'est le nucléaire ou le
charbon
aujourd'hui on n'a pas le choix
l'hydroélectrique ne suffira pas il
investit quand même dans les énergies
renouvelables
et aujourd'hui cette réelle oui mais
aujourd'hui on part dans une direction
d'electric d'abord il ya deux montagnes
de faut le savoir il ya des montagnes de
batteries qui sont en train de se créer
en chine mais on sait bien que non mais
oui non mais aller dans les
qualifications il faut il a été
d'ailleurs non seulement sur la question
des débuts c'est ça a été dit revoilà ne
misons pas forcément sur l'hybride ou
sur tout électrique
aussi les gènes végétaux les gaz il ya
eu les mots j'ai très bien
le gain le jeune mais qui bien qu on
peut produire par biomasse est à dire on
en brûlant nos propres déchets donc et
qui concerne le gène vais très bien et
peut-être plus que l'électrique donc on
part dans une direction technologique et
carlos tavares n'a pas dit le contraire
il est l'objet dans son monde dans une
certaine direction un peu irrationnel
d'electric alors qu'il s'est pas la
solution aujourd'hui faire attention à
près de solutions dépassés solution
alors iscar à aller risque avec cette
mesure
c'est l'effondrement du marché
automobile d'occasion peut-être la cote
des véhicules diesel ne risque pas de
deux chutes et peut-être avec cette
situation
nicolas très bonne mesure alors bien sûr
on çà ne concernerait que cent mille
voitures mais c'est déjà ça
c'est déjà ça c'est concret c 2 1000
euros sur une voiture de 3500 euros
c'est un site vraiment à changer son
vieux diesels sont vieillis sont vieux
et ça s'est très très bien maintenant
woods sur le le diesel on est tombée à
50%
qui va acheter un vieux diesels
aujourd'hui à part pour le mettre à la
casse dans quelques temps mais il va y
avoir une mutation
il ya forcément un peu de casse c'est
pour ça que je vous dis que augmenter le
prix du diesel c'est pas une solution
besson le faisons nous confiance faisons
confiance aux français pas sur nos
entrepreneurs pour dire ça coûte plus
cher c'est plus cher à l'entretien ça
peut le plus
faites moi confiance d'un sens civique
versé de l'essence qu'est ce qu'on
propose comme transition a comme
solutions justement réponse des villes
et des agglomérations passées à la brève
je pense que la vraie réponse et c'est
essayer de trouver des alternatives à la
voiture et modèle de la voiture
ça fait maintenant un certain nombre
d'années que une réflexion doit être
devrait être porté sur les questions
d'aménagement c'est comment on fait
aujourd'hui pour travailler au
rapprochement entre le domicile
le travail c'est à dire travailler et
avec les entreprises et avec les
collectivités pour essayer de plutôt que
de d'avoir encore cette politique
d'ailleurs qui était un cas était encore
développé quelques années de clusters
c'est-à-dire refaire la défense refaire
sa clé refaire europa city vous voyez où
on va faire venir
absolument et les travailleurs et les
consommateurs un endroit précis c'est
comment on arrive aujourd'hui à
redistribuer l'activité et créer une
mixité une mixité fonctionnelle au
travers du télétravail il ya vraiment
une partie référencera caractéristiques
peut-être les transports en commun et
puis l'autre axe c'est réellement les
transports en commun transport en commun
ou le développement des modèles tiffin
trois déplacements sur quatre cents
chansons des déplacements qui sont
internes
un bassin de vie c'est à dire que cdc
des déplacements qui sont loin de 3 km
et sur lequel on peut avoir aujourd'hui
des alternatives avec des aménagements
adéquats qui peuvent être autour de la
marche du vélo on a comme ça tout un
panel de réflexion qui qui sont qui sont
aujourd'hui portés mais qui peine
aujourd'hui encore à être mise en place
parce que on a malgré tout une classe
politique parfois veut peut-être aller
vite métier aujourd'hui se raconte à
cette histoire sur demain la voiture
autonome intelligente et partager donc
il faut continuer quand je le vois la
région ile de france il faut continuer à
faire un plan ou de 200 millions pour en
faire encore un petit peu de voirie pour
relever la concession pour pouvoir
améliorer la qualité de l'air c'est vrai
que par rapport aux politiques moi je
vois beaucoup de conférences de
transport et mobilité tout le monde
repart en voiture à paris les trois
quarts
donc c'est bien on parle de la voiture
on parle du bélon toujours pas rouvert
alors il s'est excusé excusez moi je
m'absente sont pas en voiture mais
aujourd'hui il ya 80% des déplacements
qui se font avec la voiture
nous notre philosophie à l'automobile
club association c'est on défend les
automobilistes et la mobilité
individuelle avec tous les moyens mis à
notre disposition avec la voiture aussi
alors avec un moyen de énergique qui
sera ce qu'il sera mais rien ne pourra
remplacer
donc on a un qui star au xxème siècle
sur cette possibilité de se déplacer
individuellement et il faut garder cette
richesse et cette possibilité imaginer
une voiture connectée autonome dans 40
ans on sera un peu plus âgés peut-être
pas en mesure de conduire
peut-être que juste vocalement demandera
notre portable de venir à une voiture en
bas de chez nous on montera dans la
voiture on donnera vocalement l'adresse
à nous ça nous emmènera à voir nos
petits-enfants ou ou à mon club de
bridge ou ce que vous voulez quoi on
peut avoir ça il faut garder cette
mobilité individuelle qui ne sera pas
forcément polluantes
pourquoi sortir la voiture 10 villes
avec une infrastructure qu'on est en
train de modifier dans paris qui n'est
pas la france et dans les autres villes
ça se passe pas comme ça alors que on
veut que dans 20 ans la voiture ne soit
plus polluants donc on la sort pour rien
finalement s'avère que une formation
joue direct formation à l'éco-conduite
on gagne 20 % à 91 places de
stationnement dans les villes il ya 20 %
de voitures qui tournent en permanence
elle se gare facilement dans moins de
pollution effectivement les normes sur
le diesel qui ont été falsifiés il faut
des vrais norme ça nous sommes tout à
fait d'accord mais avec des choses
simples
le covoiturage excellent covoiturage il
faut absolument développer surtout sur
de courtes distances
si on met tout ça en place on réduit la
pollution de 30 à 40% et déjà en a moins
de soucis mais il ya la question de la
pollution bio aussi la question de la
place de l'automobile dans l'espace
public aujourd'hui faire une place fort
avoir reçu et relire d'une petite
commune rurale en l'espace de huit ans
on a on a une multiplication de nombre
de voitures par foyer
alors on tournait à 2 maintenant on est
mort trois voire quatre
maintenant que les enfants oui enfin bon
ça sauf que il faut il va falloir
trouver un autre mode d'organisation
aujourd'hui je n'ai plus de place faute
de transports en commun
faute de transports en commun et c'est
pour ça qu'ils effectuent veut plus que
moi je ne suis pas aujourd'hui à dire
étant maire d'une petite commune rurale
sans aucun moyen de transport collectif
on a en plus un réseau scolaire qui est
complètement à contre sens des des gares
et des accès bien évidemment qu'il faut
qu'on continue à avoir une capacité à
pouvoir déplacer se déplacer ça c'est
certain mais accepté trois ou quatre
voitures par foyer ça c'est plus
acceptable parce que de toute façon ça
prend énormément des espaces publics
faire des parkings
ça prend l'espace public et on est quand
même dans une bosse métropoles urbaines
sur lesquels il va y avoir de plus en
plus de densification de plus en plus de
personnes et eu à un moment donné on ne
pourra pas avoir chacun qu'il faut
réglementer le nombre de voitures de
véhicules par foyer c'est patent
réglementé mais c'est en tout cas
accompagné au travers de devrait devrait
un solution enfin à l'époque les
entreprises fameux suivi la vallée
d'automobiles en plus ça tombe bien
enfin renault un peu vos avait des bus
de ramassage des déchets
leurs visas ayant maintenant c'est
compliqué de façon certaine pendant de
couper mais dans toutes les conférences
auxquelles je vais et dans les ateliers
de propositions auxquelles on fait
partie l'automobile club association -
et d'autres personnes ce qui ressort
majoritairement et à mettre en place
rapidement qui est faisable avec les
applications qui existent aujourd'hui
c'est le covoiturage à courte distance
pour arrêter d'être seul ou 1,2 dans sa
voiture le matin à deux personnes ne
serait ce que dans la région parisienne
à deux personnes bien plus de congestion
deux personnes syrien quoi il faut
vraiment mettre le paquet là dessus on
va arriver à moins de voitures plus de
détende une meilleure vie et on peut
circuler librement
ça vaut vraiment la peine de mettre le
paquet sur ce coup voiturage et c'est
l'histoire le covoiturage moi j'y crois
j'ai pris un coup mais aussi le
développement de modes actifs c'est à
dire faire prendre conscience que le
vélo vae
ça c'est utile voilà les vélos à 605 pas
peut-être aussi sur du court terme
enfin l'assemblée de supprimer la date
de sa collection plaisirs charnels
il remporte aussi un bon ben vous
débrouillez vous leur donnerez quel
mauvais messages contradictoires que
l'on passe effectivement sur sur les
questions de mobilité alors en avance le
plan 2042 nicolas hulot vise à terme
donc à supprimer les voitures avec du
carburant essence un mot qui revient
exactement long terme c'est un moteur
thermique moteur thermique donc essence
et diesel donc plus plus de voiture
comme ça les véhicules électriques et
hybrides concerne actuellement 5 % du
parc alors 2040 tout 100 électrique vous
y croyez
concrètement pardon mais c'est pour ça
que son site et sur le thème thermique
on parlait du gnv du gaz naturel le
devis ou véhicule qui peut lui quasiment
- quasiment pas tu peux lui pas
d'ailleurs la sortie et qu'on peut je
devrais peut être fourni créé par part
vous par biomasse c'est un moteur
thermique donc ce le terme générique de
dire plus de moteur thermique ça marche
pas et on va plus en vendre en france et
on fait quoi à côté on est dans l'europe
et est ce qu'on pourra ne pas les vendre
mais circuler quand même pas il ya des
précisions à voir on est d'accord encore
une fois il faut aller vers moins de
pollution vers moins de l'utilisation
des énergies fossiles en désaccord mais
à leers la france
oui mais quoi voilà là il faut faire
attention aux termes on est d'accord
faut y aller mais il ya des des termes
un peu génériques comme ça qu'ils sont
on le voit bien on en discute là qui
sont pas applicables kizomba applicable
et puis effectivement je pense qu'entre
libre il ya beaucoup qui avait détruit
d'agression a dit souhaiter retire les
cas aujourd'hui en tout cas sur ce sont
vraiment les eaux calmes et on n'a pas
de solution en france chez mercedes en
allemagne travaillent déjà ça va nous
présenter à voir alors moi je pense que
2040 c'est vraiment le cap qui a été
fixée pour en tout cas préparer les
constructeurs automobiles à investir
aujourd'hui en recherche-développement
pour un devoir être très effectivement
ça dure mais effectivement pu dégager
les chiottes vacarme et la pile à
hydrogène
je pense que ça peut être on a quinze
ans les mains libres aux jeunes 13 ans
qu'il avait rencontrée par notamment air
liquide
il ya tout baigne toute la question de
l'approvisionnement et ça ça doit se
faire également avec l'état j'imagine
qu'il ya un plan d'accompagnement pour
pouvoir atteindre ses objectifs en 2040
mais là encore si on arrêtait pensez
toujours le tout routier est con
re développer le fret ferrer le fret
fluvial et la réorganisation du flux
logistiques parce que parce que
finalement on continue encore
aujourd'hui on commence tous ceux chez
amazon on passe trois produits on reçoit
troyes où les différentes abandonné il
va falloir réellement qu'on réfléchisse
non pas simplement sur la question de la
motorisation et du flux routiers mais
comment on arrive à réorganiser une
société autour de du déplacement de la
personne et la marée de la marchandise
et des marchandises pour pouvoir
articuler et faire en sorte d'optimiser
en fait chaque déplacement
ouais je vais les références juste pour
il y avait un professeur suisse qui
venait de proposer trois prospectifs
trois perspectives de futures sociétés
alors c'était des propositions eva la
proposition qu'on en avait marre de se
déplacer ce que qu'on se fatiguer à trop
se déplacer et que ce serait les objets
qui viendrait nous grâce aussi au
télétravail en aurait moins besoin de se
déplacer c'est peut-être aussi une
société qui nous attend parce que c'est
fatigant quand même de se déplacer dans
des mauvaises conditions
et puis on parle de transport en commun
moi dans le parisien et dans aujourd'hui
en france est sorti un article pour dire
que les couloirs étaient dix fois plus
polluant particules fines qu'au dessus
donc ce n'est pas une solution non plus
de mettre tout le monde dans les
transports en commun donc on n'a pas de
solution il faut bien sûr retrouver
multiplient
il faut les chercher haut multiplier les
moyens les moyens de circulation mais
gardez cette automobile avec quoi que ce
soit qui l' aquila qu'il a des places
mais ce moyen de pouvoir être autonome
individuellement c'est merveilleux quand
même il ya vraiment une question il ya
une question sanitaire il ya une
question de santé publique
il faudra vite et dans ce cadre là merci
à tous les deux c'est la fin de cette
émission mais que c'est un débat très
riche consacré ce soir à la hausse de la
fiscalité sur le diesel
l'émission est à revoir sur notre site
internet et a commenté toujours sur les
réseaux sociaux
bonne soirée et à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]